SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO PLAY A
LITTLE GAME-- AND BY THE WAY,
ALEX WAGNER HAD THE RUN, SO WE
HAVE THE LOVELY LINDA PICATTI
FROM OUR STUDIO AUDIENCE JOINING
US.
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT, LINDA,
WHAT'S YOUR LAST MEAL?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> MY LAST MEAL WOULD HAVE TO BE
POPEYE'S SPICY.
( APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT YOU WENT FOR THE
SPICY FOR YOUR LAST MEAL BECAUSE
YOU'RE LIKE INDGESTION, WHO
CARES?
I'M OUT OF HERE.
WHAT WAS YOUR CRIME?
>> WELL, I'M A VERY LOW-TECH
PERSON.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I HATE IS
BEING IN CROWDS, FAMILY,
FRIENDS-- WHATEVER-- AND
EVERYONE'S CONNECTED TO THEIR
PHONE.
NO ONE'S, YOU KNOW--
>> WE'RE LIKE BONNIE & CLYDE.
>> Larry: I KNOW.
>> NO ONE IS TALKING TO EACH
OTHER.
EVERYONE IS CONNECTED TO THEIR
PHONE.
AND YOU KNOW THAT EXPRESSION TO
BLOW UP THE PHONE.
WELL I DID.
>> Larry: OH, MY GOD!
SHE BLEW UP HER CONTACT LIST.
MAN!
GO AHEAD AND REACH IN AND SEE
WHAT YOU GOT.
REACH INTO THE "BAG OF DEATH."
>> OH!
LICKED TO DEATH BY PUPPIES.
>> OH, LICKED TO DEATH BY
PUPPIES.
THAT'S NOT SO BAD.
AT LEAST IT'S NOT CATS.
BECAUSE THAT'S-- YEAH.